Now, we're going to begin this Reiki session by, first of all, relaxing.
You can use your own technique, if you like, or you can follow the technique we last used, which is just to scum the body up from the soles of the feet, up the legs, and then the front of the body up to the neck and across the shoulders, down the arm.
the house and then from the back of the bottom going up of the spine to the neck over the head down to the forehead and the mask of the face just take a few seconds to do that
And now we lay the foundation for good practice by reciting the precepts.
So hands in gassho.
So together.
Just for today I will be thankful.
Just for today I will be free from anger and fear.
Just for today I will be honest and kind.
Just for today I will be thankful.
Just for today, I will be free from anger and fear.
Just for today, I will be honest and kind.
Just for today, I will be thankful.
Just for today, I will be free from anger and fear.
Just for today, I will be honest and kind.
And now we're going to do
exercise which we know is body driving so if we could start with this feet pointing straight forward shoulder width apart hands to the side slightly away from the body and we breathe in and lift the
right hand towards the left shoulder sweep across the body to the right hip and down now do the same with the left hand now repeat the first movement right hand to the left shoulder breathing in
and as you breathe out drop the tongue down breathe out through the mouth and sweep it across now the left hand is presented with the palm of my fist right hand breathe in bring it to the shoulder the left shoulder and sweep down as you breathe out turn the hand now bring the left hand to the right shoulder
down turn the hand repeat the first motion right hand to the left shoulder sweep down as we breathe out turn both hands down
Now the left hand presented in front of the body with the palm touching upwards.
Right hand to the left shoulder.
Now say with the left hand.
Right hand again.
Left hand.
Raise to the front with the palm of your hand.
Right hand to the left shoulder.
The hands are placed on the thighs with the palms facing upward.
We draw the Reiki energy through the crown.
Just a bunch of you being drawn through the crown as you breathe in.
Down to the horror just below the navel.
hold it for a few seconds and imagine it beginning to spread permeate the body slowly and then breathe out and focus on it coming out of the extremities and every pore really of the body but if you focus on the hands and the feet that's usually quite effective okay let's do that
and now we visualize an oval.
We are inside the oval and as we exhale try to feel the energy going into that oval and gradually the oval just expands a little, a little more.
exercise now we stand and do the three diamonds set of exercises these feet hip width apart or whatever is comfortable hands to the sides
as we breathe in we make contact with the energy deep in the earth and bring it up into the horror as we breathe out we maintain that connection
So that is sensing earth key.
The second exercise in this set is sensing heaven key.
And for this we visualize a sphere of a color that you're happy with.
It could be blue or whatever you feel comfortable with.
White.
We visualize the sphere above the head.
As we breathe in, draw it down into the heart.
and then into the heart.
And as we breathe out,
and the final section of this set is sensing heart ki the blending of earth energy with the energy of heaven and sky so we bring the hands into a position above level with the chest as though embracing a tree okay
lower the house scoop up the energy from the earth feel the rushing energy from the sky coming down down into the center of the chest and breathe out just live on
continue raising their arms feeling the energy coming down to meet the energy of the earth breathe out back to the heart where they blend below the arms
breathing out.
So to this point we've been exercising in receptivity, being receptive of the energy that is all around us, the chi, the ki, the prana that holds everything together, the life force.
And now we're going to receive the energy of Reiki
the compassionate healing energy of Reiki, through the crown, down into the body, into the palm.
So first we raise our hands in gassho, high on the forehead, and ask for the Reiki energy to flow freely for our highest and greatest
May the energy of Reiki flow freely for our highest and greatest good.
The hands over the eyes.
Be aware of sensations
You can let the palms float away from the eyes, occasionally, just to get a feel of whatever is coming from the surface of the skin.
Even if it's just a heat, get a feel for it.
So the focus is there.
Imagine an attitude of acceptance.
the arms out, welcoming this wonderful healing energy coming down, down from above, flowing freely through the crown, down along the shoulders, along the arms and into the palms.
Now bring the hands to the side, the temples or the ears.
Then we reinforce the flow of energy by doing for this particular position in the cleansing again.
So just imagine the energy coming through the crown.
Draw it down.
the hara hold it a while letting it spread imagine it spreading and as you breathe out fully going out through the hands and the feet this time
As you exhale, imagine an oval around the body.
Exhale into that oval.
Now move the hands to the back of the head.
It's all around us, the Roki energy.
You can feel it in the air, you can feel it in the trees.
There's no doubt about it.
It's very powerful.
And it can be channeled into compassionate healing energy in the practice of Reiki.
So feel it coming through the crown.
Or just let it come, let it come.
now bring the hands to the throat one hand with the palm over the top of the sternum and the other one underneath the lower jaw very gently
note any heat, any sensations in the hands.
It helps to keep the attention in the area where
Now move the hands to the first position, top of the chest.
And go straight into inner cleansing at this point.
It's a good focal point to do that to remind us to clear the avenues for the energy of Reiki to flow down.
down into the arms and palms.
Keep the focus on the palms.
Note any tingling sensations or sensations of heat.
Now to the lower ribcage.
Be sure to keep the fingers and the thumbs together in contact and the two hands touching at the point where the fingers access each other.
Focus on the palms.
I'll move the hands into the ingridial fold
and we'll again practice the inner cleansing.
The horror position would have come there, which is also a good place, a very good place, practicing that, but we'll do it now, okay?
Focus on the palms, notes, any sensations.
As you breathe out, feel the, the oval expand.
Right, now lift the hands, we'll just put the hands over the heart for a little bit there.
So for some reason that was missed out, so we'll just spend a few seconds there.
Note the sensations around the fingers and along the palm.
the heel of the hand, the hollow of the palm, the length of the fingers.
Note any difference of sensation, any distinction in the sensation of heat between the hands
Feel that acceptance in the powerful ki, the reiki flowing from above.
Now choose a place that you feel you would love to give attention to and again imagine this acceptance, this welcoming of a free flowing powerful energy
Now place one hand on the forehead and one hand on the heart.
We have two polarities here.
Move from one palm to the other.
We welcome the flow of energy.
Truffling through the crown, moving along the arm.
Can we feel both palms at the same time?
We move from one palm to the other.
Feel the nourishing power.
Bring the hand down from the forehead.
finally cross the arms across the chest and mentally ask the Reiki to continue working
Feel highest and greatest good.
Still feel the heat.
Now we bring the hands together in gassho, raising them higher in the forehead.
And mentally give thanks for the healer.
And then it's just...